ازدهار هو قرار التزويد اذا حصل بحد ذاته
سيكون خرقا لخطوط حمر معينه ولكن في الحرب
الاوكرانيه بعد سنه ونيف لم نرى هذا
التاثير الكبير للطائرات الجويه ان كان
الروسيه او حتى الاوكرانيه المرحله
القادمه هي مرحله استعداد لهجوم كما يقال
من خلال المؤشرات هي عمليه استكمال
المنظومه الدفاع الجوي الطائران من اجل
عدم السماح للقوات الروسيه الجويه
بالهيمنه او السيطره الجويه على الارض
الاوكرانيه وبالتالي نذهب الى حتى مستوى
المقاتل وتدريبي فاذا هناك منظومه معين
ولكن يعتبر هذا الامر انه مهم خرق لخطوط
الحمر ولكنه جاهز للاستعمال بسبب التجانس
في العقيده العسكريه الشرقيه المنظومه
الاكثر تاثيره في معادله هذه
المنظومه الاكثر تاثيرا ازدهاريا الدفاعات
الجويه
الذخيره وهنا يبدا المشكله الكبرى لدى
الغرب الدبابه ونوعيه العسكر وجهوزيته
للقتال في مرحله لاحقه يعني اليوم لا يمكن
انتاج جندي مكلف له خبره في وقت قصير وهذا
الامر التلام علي الحكومه الاوكرانيه من
قبل الاوكرانيه من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انه لماذا الاستهلاك للنخبه
العسكريه في منطقه مخبوط او مدينه بخموت
ولماذا لا الانسحاب هذه المنظومه يجب ان
تكون جاهزه لاي عمل عسكري مستقبلي وهذا
يفتح الباب للتساؤل عن منظومه الطيران او
الطائرات لماذا هي غير مؤثره حتى الان في
هذه الحرب حتى روسيا لا تستخدمها لماذا في
تقديرك
الكثير من الاسئله يعني روسيه اليوم عندما
تستعمل هذه الطائرات اذا اسقطت الطائره
واحده لها تاثير معنوي وعسكري اثنين روسيه
تستعمل الطائرات والقصف باتجاه اوكرانيا
من داخل الاراضي الروسيه لذلك يقال انه اي
الطائره الاوكرانيه قد تقاتل وتضرب
الطائرات الروسيه يجب ان تدخل الى الاراضي
الروسيه وهذا امر يعتبر تبوك او يعتبر من
الخطوط الحمر لدى الرئيس بايدن وحتى لدول
الناتو من هنا هذه لم تكن مؤثره حتى في
اليوم الاول لم يكن هناك تاثير كبير
للطيران الجوي الروسي في العمليه وبدء
الحرب على اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك من
بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي